you know back when roger goodell signed
his most recent contract
then nfl spokesman joe lockhart said
that would be goodell's final contract
goodell quickly said no it won't and not
long after that lockhart was gone so as
the train keeps rolling forward in roger
goodell's career peter king addressed
the situation in football morning in
america sitting here today peter what's
your best guess what's the over under if
points bet we're going to create odds of
the roger goodell retirement what would
be the over under of number of years
left before he walks off into the sunset
five
because his contract allows for three
calls for three more years
21 22 and 23 then his contract is up
and
roger goodell even among close
associates has not discussed
openly or very very much even privately
what he wants to do other than
the fact that all of these people who
know him well
told me uniformly or several of them
told me uniformly
roger's not a big
habit guy
you know he's not he doesn't long to go
fishing in the outer banks he doesn't
want to go on a two-week golf vacation
to scotland
he does love golf
uh he belongs to augusta
but but you know what he wants
is
to do this job which he really likes to
do he's in good health and he is in
uh
he's in form right now
after getting the collective bargaining
agreement done after getting the
television contract done you know both
within the span of one year
mike
the reason joe lockhart said that stuff
is that everybody in the league felt
that when this when those two things
were done roger goodell would begin to
have an exit strategy
well far from it i am told
that he has been even though he's got a
a leadership team that has been working
more than in any other year because they
had to get this
coveted season played
that he has been all on them about
keep your eye on the next thing we have
to make sure that we keep going no
complacency inside this office
and look that's been his attitude all
along trying always to get better in
what the nfl does and this is a guy who
30 40 years ago his aspiration was to be
the commissioner of the nfl so
he he reached his goal in 2006 15 years
later there's no reason for him to stop
physically mentally professionally you
just keep going and
there's there are no immediate
challenges per se now how they deal with
gambling the potential threats that that
gambling brings to the game integrity
issues inside information as gambling
grows that's something they're going to
have to worry about it's something
they're going to have to deal with and
they need to be proactive not reactive
beyond that though there are no icebergs
in sight and there are no icebergs that
are hiding you've got a cba that lasts
for another decade and the one thing
about the tv deals that didn't get
covered the way that it should
because we heard about how all these
deals are in place until
2031 or 2032 there's an out that the nfl
holds in every one of these contracts
after seven years i believe it is so by
the end of the decade they're gonna be
pulling the plug on all these tv deals
and re doing them and that may be when
streaming fully takes over who knows
but uh and i don't know that that's a a
negative i don't know that that's
something he'd not want to be there for
i think it's an opportunity to take
whatever they have now and make even
more money but you know there are no
storms on the horizon for roger goodell
so why not just keep pushing the boat
forward why and again if there's not
some other thing that you're you're just
dying to do
over however many years you have left
then why not keep doing the thing that
you're good at that you always wanted to
do and you still have a passion for
there's no reason to walk away from it
look pete carroll is 69
bill belichick is 69.
roger goodell is 62.
and you would think that
the stressors in all three of those men
in in the jobs of all three of those men
maybe not be identical but
they probably do have a lot of stress in
their lives
and look
you know you ask people who know roger
goodell and he's like he's maniacal
about getting on his uh you know getting
on his elliptical or doing the peloton
or
you know whatever
he's
he is conscious of the fact that he
needs to be in good shape to do a job
that is as demanding as this job and so
he takes that seriously i mean he's not
a
not a joe fitness guy but he's fit
enough
and so i think that
for for everyone like me
who thought when he signed this contract
that he was going to be gone soon after
you know getting these two deals done
you know the one other thing we haven't
talked about mike is the fact that
right now other than there's probably
some patches
uh down in jerry world you know down in
texas with jerry jones you know who
knows
maybe even with daniel snyder in
washington i don't know but there are
going to be some people who would say
hey yeah probably time for old roger to
move on but i am told pretty reliably
that at least
three quarters of the owners in the
league
want goodell to continue
when his contract expires in 2023 after
the 23 season so
absent
a movement
a verified
uh
movement of any sort i i think he's
going to sign another contract and i
think he will be around now how many
more years two three uh you know i don't
know but i would guess
that if i had the over under right now
it'd be hard for me to pick
uh five years
whether i would go over or under that
and uh we need to take a break but one
last point and we wrote something about
this and this is something i've heard
multiple times over the course of the
past couple of years as the nfl
continues to grow as these franchises
move toward thanks to the infusion of
cash from gambling 10 billion in
valuation each and that's coming
there is a thought that the next
commissioner won't just be
the lieutenant who's been groomed
internally who knows how the sport works
or the guy from a team that has the
connections that at some point they're
going to need to start hiring
traditional ceos and there's a ceo
industry
people who have a unique skill set in
running a multi-multi multi-billion
dollar operation and then you have the
football people who are part of the
leadership team the nfl may need
professional ceo as a replacement for
roger goodell by the time he walks away
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports